Let's look at the solution to the second part of this quiz,
which is about figuring out, when do these two instructions issue dispatch and
write results. We first have to figure out when the add here will issue.
Normally, it would issue in cycle five, assuming that the reservation station is
available. Let's check whether a reservation station is available in cycle five.
At this time we have already issued two ADDs, so
we can occupy both of the reservation stations. So one is available here,
only if one of these two ADDs frees our reservation station before a cycle five.
So reservation station is available only if one of these two frees its
reservation station before cycle five. Note that our reservation station needs
to be freed a cycle earlier than when we allocate it, so if we are going to
use it in cycle five, it needs to be freed in cycle four. Unfortunately,
these two adds do not release their reservation stations until cycles 10 and 12.
The first one that becomes available will be freed in cycle ten.
It cannot be allocated to this add immediately. So
this add can only issue in cycle 11 because it needs this reservation station.
Once this add issues, it might dispatch in cycle 12, assuming
that it has no dependencies. And indeed, it doesn't. So it issues in cycle 12,
and then executes for one cycle, and broadcasts its result in cycle 13.
The next add here will issue in cycle 12,
because issue needs to be done in order. So if this one issues in cycle 11,
the next add in the program order will not be considered for
issuing until cycle 12. So we will try cycle 12, but
we have to check whether a reservation station is available. This add by then
has freed the reservation station but these two are still holding onto theirs.
Note that this add here is freeing its reservation station in cycle 12, but
it cannot be allocated to a new instruction in the same cycle. So
this add here actually issues in cycle 13, and then it doesn't wait for
anything because F3 and F4 are not produced by previous instructions. So
it will dispatch in cycle 14 and finally write it's result in cycle 15.